pues este paseo vacunal estará ahora
será la obligación para todos los
mayores de 16 años aquí en francia a
partir de este lunes como usted bien lo
explicaba e indica que todas estas
personas tendrán que presentar este
documento que está ya sea en sus
teléfonos móviles o ya sea en un papel
que le entregan a uno cuando ya uno pues
se tiene esa pauta de vacunación o
completa y eso tiene un código qr es era
ese código el que uno tendrá que
presentar para poder ya sea tomar un
transporte público entre regiones ir a
un bar a un restaurante ir a algún lugar
de ocio como por ejemplo al cine al
teatro algún tipo de conciertos para
todo eso va a tener que presentarse ese
documento a partir de este lunes hay
algunas excepciones para las personas
que por ejemplo están comenzando su
pauta de vacunación para que ese pase
todavía esté válido pero en ese caso sí
tendrán que demostrar por ejemplo una
persona que tan solo tiene por ahora la
primera dosis tendrá que presentar un
test negativo ya sea de antígeno o pcr
para poder entrar a esto lugares dentro
de todo luego que avaló este consejo
constitucional pues lo cierto es que hay
una parte y es que para las personas que
vayan a ir a algún tipo de evento
digamos de reuniones políticas meeting
de mítines de campaña justamente ahora
cuando comienza a toda esta carrera por
la presidencia en francia pues estas
personas no tendrán no se les podrá
exigir ese pase de vacunación ya que
consideran pues que esto podría vulnerar
los derechos fundamentales de los
ciudadanos
y es bueno esta medida ha generado gran
polarización y protestas dentro del país
hay algún recurso que puedan presentar
los opositores para evitar que sea
obligatorio
en realidad el recurso era este
finalmente porque es este consejo
constitucional que tiene está
constituido por nueve miembros son los
sabios así se les conoce son ellos
quienes tienen que mirar si éste el
proyecto de ley el texto de un proyecto
de ley va acorde o no a la constitución
del país y bueno ya pues con esta
decisión que ellos toman el día de hoy
en la que avalan la mayor parte de este
texto pues no hay mucho más que hacer de
hecho incluso validaron una parte de
este texto que causaba bastante polémica
y era que por ejemplo en los cafés y en
los restaurantes se pueda verificar la
identidad de la persona en el momento en
que está mostrando ese pase sanitario
eso sí dijeron que debían en todo caso
evitar que esto llevara a algún tipo por
ejemplo de discriminación y que lo único
que pueden hacer en este caso en caso de
que la identidad pues no corresponda a
la persona que esté presentando el pase
de vacunación simplemente sea que no
pueda ingresar a un establecimiento